hi brother it's great to have you here
on flicks in the city again today that
was some incredible season 5 finale what
did he think after seeing the episode
yourself well I knew I knew what was
going to happen for my storyline but I
was equally excited for like Aria
storyline and Cersei storyline just to
see where they went and it all came to a
real climax in that episode I thought
like all the major storylines Stannis as
well and Brienne and Sansa it's just so
much in one episode that yeah it was
great and what did you think when you
saw Jon Snow stabbed on-screen well I
was I was quite lucky I got to see it in
ADR so I got sort of in-between process
when they had all the footage put into
the cuts that they wanted but didn't
have any like effects with the knife or
any other music so when when they added
that it had a whole new layer to it so
yeah it was incredible to see and what
did you think when you saw yourself
stabbing Jon Oh instantly I thought
right okay Twitter's gonna go until this
because it's Jon Snow
say so yeah it was a bit of like amazing
that it looked brilliant in my eyes but
but yeah it was a little bit of okay
where's this gonna go and what did he
feel when you saw the reaction fans had
oh it was I was blown away it was it's
still going on its mental because I've
got the two complete contrasting sides
I've got the fans who are like oh no we
love Jon why'd you have to do this
you're the worst character in it and
then I've got the people who understand
that it's not reality and they're saying
oh well done for the scene all the way
your character so so yeah I'm getting
hate from both sides but one of them's a
bit more a bit more loving now we talked
the other day about the nodding Olly
tumbler yeah and now I'm guessing you've
seen the [ __ ] Olly hashtag on Twitter
yeah we also the subreddit [ __ ] Olly but
also the only rule subreddit what do you
a couple lads yeah so I heard about them
and that I had to look myself and some
of the stuff on there is just crazy like
I still think of Olly is like this tiny
little character who is just there by
chance like I'm only on Game of Thrones
by chance I'm not in the books or
anything so yet I have all of that going
on for this tiny character is mental
what's your favorite comments picture
gift vine or meme that you've seen so
far oh I heard a terrible terrible but
brilliant at the same time joke the
other day that one roommates told me
said why was John Snow queuing at the
Apple Store and I said why and he said
for the watch you mentioned the book sir
did you know the books at all I've not
read them but my my dad hasn't quite a
few more mates have so they knew it was
coming and they were like are you
involved and I was I can't say but yeah
well my mates were quite happy with the
way it looked like they had no idea it
was coming for the two series for the
kindling Ygritte storyline and the
kimandjohn storyline so yeah I sort of
just amazed by oh really how does the
reaction to you're stabbing Jon compared
to when you shot Ygritte and gave that
little nod well the the Ygritte one I
still I did get a little bit of hate and
my favorite comment from that was just
one fan on Twitter saying you should
have been eaten so so yeah that was yes
I got that from him it's it's been 10
times like a hundred times bigger
reaction for Jon but just constant phone
buzzing all the time from people on
Twitter so yeah it's great now Game of
Thrones fans are in disbelief that Jon
Snow could be dead in the books as a
hint at the possibility he might warg
into ghosts so what do you think do you
think jon is definitely dead there is no
hope Jon Snow is
more well there's so many theories going
around with the warming theory and
obviously the the Lord of Light Theory
come in that Melisandre could bring him
back but I think that in true Game of
Thrones nature I think when you kill a
character as big as that I think you've
got to stick to it
I personally I'd love to see John back
as the character and kid just because
he's a lovely guy but yet I think in
such a big program where it's known for
killing off main characters if you kill
off someone go now or only joking
they're back sort of defeats the purpose
of killing them but personally I'd like
to see him back and how would you like
to see him come back well there's two
ways either he comes back as a white and
there's this big face-off between him
and Sir Alastair which I think would be
quite interesting or I'd quite like to
see the bringing back of him from
Melisandre because that would mean he's
still human and he's still able to deal
with right and wrong and to see what the
outcome would be if Holly or him and sir
Alistair were to meet again just to see
whether John would be able to forgive
them that time you know in the episode
when we're focusing on John's face and
we see the blood flowing up the screen
it does look a little as if his eyes are
changing not as much as when we see
Cassie or the White Walkers or the
whites when their eyes suddenly light up
blue but just a little slight almost
imperceptible change now I'm not sure
whether that's just the light changing
as a camera moves in do you think that's
what it is or do you think he's going to
come back
I've been reading lots and lots about it
on on the internet all the different
theories about the eye changing and
whether it actually happens or whether
it's just a trick of the light and some
people think that it goes Targaryen
purple is one of the things I that I
discovered the other day and that would
support one of the theories from the
books but yeah I have I have no idea
what what it means or whether it really
was there in the first place but I think
that you
myself I'm in denial that John's gum
shirley's it's gotta be there and
there's the hole the dragon has three
heads theory as well with Daenerys John
and Tyrion because we don't know John or
Tyrians mothers yeah exactly
now what's your situation now you're
filming on dickensian how long are you
going to be filming that cool I don't
know how long it's gonna be
but yeah it's great fun though really
good job and I've met on me
mark Stanley who plays Grenaa Stanley
have to say about that theme oh he loved
it they loved the scene but he was
disappointed to see Jon Snow go as well
yes you're lucky there weren't more of
John supporters like people Grenaa the
wall weren't you yeah I was I was
looking out for um dollar said yes what
happened to dollar uh says I have no
idea I was looking around thinking right
so we've got ghost didn't intervene at
all and Edie who wasn't there at the
time because luckily Sam went off so Sam
the Slayer wasn't there to stop us where
and where was everyone else like
Melisandre in Davos yeah it seems to be
just just this little band of brothers
at the wall now so who knows well we
might see the consequences later on in
the series I have no idea
now I'll use the excuse that they could
find out where Benjen stark was to get
John to come down that was pretty
terrible don't you think yeah it even
when I was reading the script I was like
oh that's a low blow
cuz the one thing you don't want to do
before you murder someone is mentioned
their dead relative it's just not a cool
thing to do but it was it was clever of
them I think ser Alliser would have come
up with that the whole plan of Olly
luring him out because if he'd have gone
tried to get him out with the same
excuse he probably been more wary but
because he trusted
Olly that's why he was so quick to go
out but I think that in the eyes of the
plan and the eyes of ser Alliser it
worked very well
mentioning benjin because it obviously
had the
effective in leaving which was what we
wanted what do you think it's gonna be
next for the watch now another walk is
gonna come and are they going to live to
regret John stabbing it's got a death
it's got to be death if John doesn't
come back because there's got to be some
consequence and I think that as we've
seen in episode 8 of this series the
threat of the the whites and the white
walkers is getting more and more every
single series so who knows what they
look like in series 6 like growing and
growing
especially after hardhome so do you
think in the end that Jon Snow really
did know nothing with all of all these
glares and looks in season 5 John didn't
really pick up on them did he yeah he
didn't he didn't pick up on that
particularly well he's old turned a
blind eye to that because he thought it
was just me that I'd come round to his
way of thinking eventually once I knew
that it was the the right thing to do in
the end but sadly I didn't get the
chance to learn like that and I think
that that could be something that only
as a character might regret but I feel
as if Jon did know what was best for the
people at Castle black because he was
trying to try to stop the threat of the
White Walkers getting worse by the
addition of the wildlings so I think
that he knew what was right for them he
just was so distracted by that that he
missed out on the looks that Olly was
giving him and the hatred that was
growing yeah do you think one of his
downpours as law commander then was a
kind of inability to communicate and
turn people around to make them realise
how great this threat really was yeah I
think that would probably be is like
worst worst areas Lord Commander because
there I was a kid who is who has had
some bad experiences and had to take I
had to take drastic action to sort out
the problems that he's thought needed
sorting out without having it explained
properly by John
so yeah I think that that probably was
his downfall
now kit harington has said that he isn't
back for season six but that just makes
some people think they're going to leave
the wall until season seven then yeah
who knows I have no idea what's going on
so yeah I was in the darkest year what
would you like to see happen next well I
think that there's got to be some
movement from the whites and the white
walkers down south I maybe we'll see
them climb the wall or something or try
and climb the wall in the next series
but I think that if we do see Castle
black and the Nights Watch in the next
series there's got to be something big
like with the threat of the whites
coming it can't just be more sitting
around training what's been your
favorite part of filming season five
brennick the filming was probably just
the big mess all scenes and the the
killing of months just because there was
so many people there and just chatting
to all these amazing actors was just an
incredible experience yeah I knew filmed
in Iceland as well as Belfast what was
that like yeah for one week in series
four yeah yeah that was that was amazing
Iceland is completely different to
anywhere I've ever been because I've not
been there in the winter but I've heard
that it's like almost 20 hours of
darkness and then like a couple of hours
of dusk but in the summer it's a
complete contrast you've got like 22
hours of sunlight and then a little bit
darker for two hours then back to
sunlight again it really throws you get
really disoriented and who's been your
favorite character that you've really
enjoyed watching on the small screen so
far I think I'm gonna have to say Sam
yeah just to see the transformation from
series 1 where he comes in and confesses
he's a coward
so being Sam the Slayer and sticking up
for what he believes in and yeah and
John's are absolutely an incredible
actor so yeah it's
the storyline progression and also
seeing John actor is just a real treat
how likely is it that you think Stan
will actually discover something when he
goes to the Citadel to become a maester
knowing Sam he usually comes up with
some really good ideas and finds things
that no one else can especially in his
surroundings with rapists and murderers
where no one else really cares for books
but yeah I think knowing Sam he's
definitely gonna come up with something
and possibly ride back to Castle black
and find that John's not there or John
might be there who knows and finally
what would you like to say to fans of
the show out there after the events of
for the watch I'm so so sorry if any of
you are offended but it was in the
script it's been lovely talking to you
again Brian oh thanks so much for your
time thanks very much
you